HOI LAIM: We have got a lot,
a lot of content for you.
So onstage we have
five speakers.
Going to talk about
a variety of topics.
So I would start with Android
Wear, and some of the things
that you may not know about,
or some of the top tips
as we develop Android Wear 2.0.
Then I'm going to
have Mark, who will
give an update on Android TV.
Give us a wave.
Woo hoo.
And then we have Santiago,
who's going to give us
an update on ExoPlayer.
And then we have Aga,
who will take you
behind the scene on our
development of Android
2.0 and some the components
that we've built.
And last but definitely
not least, we
have Dan, who's going to talk
about pro audio or Android
audio.
DANIEL GALPIN: Android audio.
HOI LAIM: Android audio.
So get your hashtag ready.
Each of our speakers
have six minutes.
Actually, my clock
already started.
What's going on?
OK, so let's get going.
Android Wear.
And what I'm going
to do, I'm going
to talk about three
things that is a little
[INAUDIBLE] to developers,
and quite often is not
immediately obvious when you
develop for Android Wear.
The first thing is, if your
app is standalone, please,
please tell us.
So at the start of
Android Wear back in 2014
the only way for
the watch to connect
to the internet via the
phone through Bluetooth.
We have subsequently added both
Wi-Fi and satellite connection
to the watch, but you
still needed a phone
with Android Wear 1.0.
With 2.0 we have added a
new way for you to connect,
which is via direct
HTTP connection.
What this means is if you
have connection code based
on your mobile, you could just
reuse exactly the same code
on your watch.
So that's what's been launch
with Android Wear 2.0.
The advantages of
that is, of course,
you can run your app even if
they are paired to an iPhone.
Because there is no
additional component
required on the phone.
Another advantage is that
users can now directly install
your app from the watch itself.
We have Play Store on
the watch so the user
can download whatever
they want onto their most
personalized device.
And in order for you to tell
us that your app support
this functionality of accessing
the internet directly,
all you need to do is
put on this metadata
tag in your Android Wear
app android manifest XML.
And after you do that,
we will put your app
onto the Play Store
on the watch and it
will be accessible to both
users that's using an Android
phone as well as an iPhone.
Next, standalone architecture.
So many of you have heard
about model view controller.
So that's pretty
much done, right?
Standalone
architecture, you know,
you just put your
services in the cloud,
or your display
logic on the device.
Done, lightning talk.
In reality, it's not quite that.
So today the center of
gravity for the user
is a lot about mobile.
You know, you heard
about mobile first.
And quite often we forgot about
all the other form factors
that a user already have.
And it doesn't even need
to be another form factor.
It could just be the same
user with another phone.
And this particular pitfall
is particularly easy
to fall into if you have
a user credential that
is telephone-based,
meaning that when
a user log into one device,
you lock them out of another.
And I see this assumption being
built into app again and again.
And when they come to extend
their app to other form
factors, this really,
really hit them
because the user can only log
into one device at any one
time.
So at a very, very minimum, I
would strongly encourage you,
even if you are just startup
that is bootstrapping,
or you're working on a
project over the weekends,
build the assumption that a user
will have more than one device.
So allow multiple
security tokens
to be active at any one point.
You don't need to build
cloud-based, messaging,
synchronization, none
of that at the start.
Maybe when you get
your serious funding,
then you could do that.
The next thing that
we realized when
we start building for Android
Wear 2.0 which support all
of login is that the a lot
of the time, the first time
the user access your app
could be via the Android Wear
device, which means
that they may not
have an account to sign in.
So if you assume that
the user can just
have this sign in
button for the app,
you may be missing a
whole chunk of users.
So what we will encourage you to
do as you build an [INAUDIBLE]
experiences, also put in a
Register button so that you can
enable users that's coming
in from other form factors--
be it Android Wear,
be it Android TV--
to actually register
for your service
the very first time that
they are logging in.
Last but not least,
Android Wear for China.
So we are in China, and
it is extremely popular.
It is our second largest market
around the world behind the US.
And as you know, many
of the Google services
are not available in China.
So one of the things
that you should
do as you use Google Play
services on Android Wear
is to check that
it is available.
So there's two ways to do this.
One is when you are connecting
to the Google Play services,
check if the connection fail
that the API is available.
And then second, if you
have a variety of APIs,
let's say five of them, and you
need it, and if three of them
connect and you still want them
to work, then you could do this
and say, add API if available.
And then check that the
API is actually available
before you use it.
And there are three
types of services
that is available in China in
a Google Play services package.
The first one is Google Fit.
You can get the seven-day
step count from that.
Second, Fused Location Provider.
We really, really
recommend that you use it
if you're trying
to get location.
It has a lot of battery
optimization built in,
as well as all the
different combinations
of ways of getting location.
So just let us take
care of that for you.
Last but not least,
since Android 1.0 we
have the wear data layer.
So to use it you will
need Google Play Services.
And if you want to compile just
once, against the Google Play
Services once, for both
rest of world and China,
then you should compile
with the version 10.2.0.
And what it enables you
to do is for your app
to run both within China
and also outside of China.
So with that, I'll hand
over to Mark, who will
talk to you about Android TV.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK BACHINGER: Yeah, let's
talk about Android TV.
You've maybe already
seen the keynote
where we announced the new cool
features for Android TV coming
soon.
I'm going to talk
about two of them.
One is that Google Assistant
on Android TV, and the other
is the new lounge
screen, the new home
screen starting with Android O.
Google Assistant
goes Android TV.
That's not really
surprising news.
We want to have Google
Assistant on every surface
on every platform available.
So Android TV is just
the next logical step.
What do you need to
do as a developer
to make your app integrating
with Google Assistant?
There are basically two ways
Google Assistant interact
with your app.
First it needs to find the
content your apps provide.
So it needs a way to query
your app for content.
This is done by using
a service provider.
And second, once the
content is found,
it needs a way to
play this content.
It needs a way to remote control
your app and do playback.
For this it uses the
media session API.
Both of these are kind of
well-known technologies.
We have these on Android TVs
since the very first launch
a few years ago.
So what we see here is that
old universal or global search
that's exactly the feature
on the former Android TV
versions, which uses the service
provider as well as the Google
Assistant does.
Google Assistant now
re-uses this service
and provides a new, more
modern-looking user interface
like we see here the
presentation of the results
for the query action movies.
Now the user can choose
from these movies and start
playback.
How far is that?
These are well-known
technologies.
There's a lot of documentation
available on developer
android.com.
There is a DAC guide,
making TV apps searchable,
and there is also
a lean back sample
app, which provides sample code
which you can use and adapt
for your app.
So now Assistant now
found the content,
or the user found via Assistant
the content he wants to watch,
and now Assistant uses the media
session API to start playback.
We see here this callback
of the media session
where the media commands arrive.
And you in your app just
need to delegate these calls
to the player you are using.
In this case it's an
ExoPlayer instance.
Media session is as well
already well-documented.
There is a guide on
developer android.com
working with media session.
And there is also a media
session extension for ExoPlayer
which provides out in the box
integration with the media
session.
So now let's have a
look at the new content
first launcher experience, the
new home screen of Android TV.
We see here this
row-based layout.
On the top we see the
arrow with favorite apps.
But then we see
these channels rows.
Channel rows with programs
which an app wants to advertise
to the user for recommendation.
Each app can at least place one
such a channel row on the home
screen, and the
launcher application
takes the data to displays
these rows from a database
from a content provider.
So your app needs to insert
data into exactly this content
provider.
Let's have a look how
this looks like in code.
We have here a sample method
which adds such a channel
row to the content provider.
At the very start we just
create a builder instance,
in this case a channel builder
instance, which we then
populate with the properties
we want to use for our channel.
In the next step, we
use now this builder
to build the content values
and insert these content
values into our content
provider via the TV
contract we are using.
In the next step now we want
to add a logo to our channel.
So the user can easily recognize
to which app a row below,
is a channel row belongs.
And we use the store channel
channel logo method here
to which we pass the channel
ID and the logo as a bitmap.
Now finally, we want
to make this channel
visible on the home screen.
For this we request
it to make it
browsable with the request
channel browsable method
and pass our channel ID.
Now we have such a channel row
visible on the home screen.
And of course, we
want to add programs.
This works in the very same
way, or in a very similar way.
Again, we create a
builder instance,
and this time it's a
preview program instance.
And we populate the
data in this builder.
Most importantly the
channel ID, of course,
to which we link our
program to a given
channel we've already created.
Once we add a title,
description, and post art URI,
we now can take the
content values, again built
by our builder, and
insert it into the content
provider of the TV contract.
This API is already
documented in more detail
on developer android.com.
You'll find a guide about
displaying recommendations
in the Android TV home
screen, which provides you
with more details about how
you can maintain your channel
and program data
in the database.
With this, I'll point you to
our sandbox, Android TV sandbox,
where you can play around
with the new launcher
screen, and also the
Android TV office hours.
We are happy to answer
your detailed question
about Android TV.
With this I give over to
Santiago from the ExoPlayer
team.
SANTIAGO SEIFERT: Thank
you very much, Mark.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello.
Let's talk about ExoPlayer.
ExoPlayer is an application
level media library
for Android.
It's an alternative to
Android platform media player.
And the ExoPlayer library
has four main goals.
The first goal is to reduce
the effects of fragmentation.
Media playback on
Android has been
flagged to be one of
the most affected areas
by fragmentation.
And ExoPlayer moves the
majority of the media player
reimplementation to
the application layer.
And so it's possible to update
through regular application
updates, hence reducing the
effects of fragmentation.
Most ExoPlayer functionality
works from Jellybean onwards.
That covers the vast
majority of Android devices.
Our second goal in the least is
to provide advanced features.
So you already possibly
know that ExoPlayer
provides some features
not currently supported
by the media player API.
This includes dash, smooth
streaming, persistent caching.
There are others, but we
are also constantly working
to add new features.
So our latest additions
include a set of tools
for downloading almost
any kind of media
and playing it offline.
There is also dynamic playlists.
So you can create
dynamic playlists,
modify them on the fly.
This functionality is
also built in the player.
So if we know enough
anticipation what
media is coming, we
can shorten by a lot
the gap between items
in the playlist.
And you can do very cool stuff
with this, like for example,
[INAUDIBLE].
Which brings me to
my next feature,
which is there is this
new component called
buffer audio
processors, which allow
many interesting audio features,
like the playback speed
adjustment all the way back
from Jellybean onwards,
and spatial audio
for virtual reality.
And finally on a slightly
more technical level,
there is support for the
full sync standard now.
So we have had support for
sync for a long time now.
Well, long time,
it has been around.
And now we have added support
for the three remaining scheme
types.
Most interestingly,
these include
CBCS, which is the scheme
type required by HLS for DRM
protected content.
So this is interesting
for content providers.
This is by no means an
exhaustive list, but
[INAUDIBLE].
So there are a ton of
use cases for ExoPlayer.
We know for a fact
that no size fits all.
So the ability to customize
is one of the core principles
in ExoPlayer.
So this is our third goal,
to allow customization.
So say, for example, that you
have amazing content which
you want to stream
to Android devices
and you come up with
a custom DRM scheme.
So you create a component and
you inject it into ExoPlayer.
Then after shipping and
having some metrics,
you realize you
also want to tweak
the way you mesh your
bandwidth because the network
conditions of certain users,
you want just to tweak it.
And by the way, it's also good
to customize the adaptation
mechanism.
So you create
components for that,
you inject them to ExoPlayer.
After shipping,
taking new metrics,
you realize that you would
also like to customize
the way you buffer the media.
So you also create
all these components.
All these things you can
inject into ExoPlayer.
There are tons of hotspots for
injecting custom components
in ExoPlayer at very
different abstraction levels.
And now I'm going to speak
about our fourth goal, which
is enable easy integration
with related libraries.
Extensions are ExoPlayer modules
with external dependencies.
For example, the IMA extension.
For media distributors
who want to monetize
their media, this
extension, which
is a wrapper around the Google's
interactive media's SDK,
it makes it extremely easy to
play ads along your content.
And as a playlist, it's
integrated into the player.
So you can reduce and almost
eliminate the weight cost
by buffering [INAUDIBLE]
during media playback.
There's also the cast
extension, which is quite new.
Apps using ExoPlayer can
now almost effortlessly
cast their content into
cast compatible devices.
And you can even use
your custom UI components
if you have any
that you are using
to control ExoPlayer
to control playback
on cast compatible devices.
But Chromecast on TV is
not all we have in mind.
There is also the media
session extension,
which allows a ExoPlayer
instance to publish a media
session.
Therefore, you can control
that playback session
from other apps
in other devices.
And the images
above is being used
on a mobile device
and Android [? out. ?]
So this is very interesting.
So ExoPlayer can also use, maybe
you know in virtual reality
environments, but the
GVR extension also
adds support for spatial
audio in ExoPlayer,
which is very cool.
It's also possible thanks
to audio processors,
which I've mentioned before.
There are many other extensions.
Due to time constraints I'm
not going to delve into them.
But I just want to mention that
most of them, or many of them,
can be used to bundle
your own software
recorders into applications.
So you can make sure there is
support for specific codecs
you're looking for on all
devices you want to ship for.
So that's all from me.
Please check our
medium blogspot.
Try out the new stuff, the
new extensions, new features.
Hope to see you tomorrow
at the office hours.
Thank you very much,
I'll leave you with Aga.
[APPLAUSE]
AGNIEZKA MADURSKA:
Thank you, Santiago.
Today I wanted to spend a
little time talking about one
of the new APIs that we
launched with Android
Wear and the support library.
And it's got to do with
round screens and with lists.
So this is our new
Wear 2.0 launcher
that I started working on around
maybe a year and a half ago.
And what we wanted to
do with this launcher is
we wanted it to be fast, we
wanted it to be easy to use.
But most importantly,
we wanted it
to fit in with the curved screen
that all the new watches have.
So round watches are by far
the most popular watches
at the moment.
Users love them, and they are
much, much, much more popular
than the square ones.
So we wanted to adjust our
design to that new trend
and make it visually
more appealing and more
fitting with the round UI.
So this is how we
wanted it to look here
on the left-hand side,
which is all grand.
We knew that.
But we needed to figure
out how to implement it.
So this is what I
got from my designers
here on the right-hand side,
which generally when you first
look at it looks fabulous.
A lot of people forget that
the launcher is static.
I'm not exactly sure
why they forget,
but the launcher is
not static, I'm sorry.
You can scroll it up and down.
And once you scroll
it up and down,
you need to be able to
animate those elements
in the launcher alongside the
curve that we want to achieve.
And you don't only want to
animate them just like they
are, you want to scale them.
So you can see the
ones here at the top
are slightly smaller than
the one in the center, which
we want to focus on.
If it's in the center,
that's the focused item.
So for regular straight
lists, a lot of the work
is done by Android framework.
But when Android
was being designed
nobody exactly thought
about round screens--
like it's not a
thing for phones.
So this was a new
challenge for us.
So when I started
looking at the code,
you can see on
the left-hand side
here how the
straight list works.
It's kind of straight.
And when you scroll it, every
single element in the list
moves by the same
amount of pixels
at the same time, which creates
an illusion of scrolling.
It's really a super
simple linear function.
Now, this is not the case,
obviously, with the curved list
that we have here.
So you can see that not only
do we want to translate items
on the y-axis, we also
for the curved list
want to translate
them on the x-axis.
So I'm OK with maths.
So I figured the
function out for this.
You can translate x
to y by using a very
simple circle-based function.
So I was very
pleased with myself.
I went back to my design team,
I built a prototype, and said,
hey, you guys, it's working.
It's fine, it's looking well.
They say, Aga, this
is really not good.
No.
It's really, really terrible.
We can't launch this.
There is no way, that was
so bad, Aga, so horrible.
No way.
What we really want is this.
We want the circles to be
equidistant from each other,
how you see here, which
means you can't linearly just
translate and have the y
position exactly like you would
have it in the straight list.
You not only need to
translate in the x direction,
you also need to do
it in the y direction.
So you can see there's a
slight slope to these lines
here and here.
Also for the eagle-eyed view
here, the slope goes up here,
but on the flip side here
on the bottom it goes down.
So that just doesn't
make it easier at all.
So instead of changing
just the value of x,
we needed to change both
the values of x and y.
So this is a problem in Android.
Because once you change the
x or y values of any view,
that triggers a new
layout path each time.
So if you're changing y in
a vertically scrolling list,
you will trigger a layout pass
on, and on, and on, and on,
and on, because the old value--
sorry, the new value is
treated as an old value
on the next pass.
And this is obviously
not what we wanted,
or that would completely kind of
block the device, so not cool.
So instead of changing
the value of y,
we decided to translate the
view by just a little bit.
So that is a very
subtle difference.
Translations in Android do
not trigger a layout pass.
So this was a simple
solution, and we
were pleased with it to
implement it in the launcher.
But as you can see, this is
probably not a unique problem.
So we discovered that actually
it works for us for the curve,
but it could work
for any other path.
So that's why on the top of
the solution for the long term,
my team built an
API that enables
you to use any chosen path,
however funky it might be,
right?
Like this thing here.
I mean, if you want
to implement it,
you can implement it, basically.
I don't know why, but you can.
And the only caveat is that we
will not give you the maths.
We will not do
the maths for you.
I had enough of maths.
So we will give you a container,
the wearable recycler view.
We will give you
all the callbacks.
But you need to supply
us with the path.
And then how the path is used
is a little bit like this.
So this will go live in Android
O when it drops to open source.
This is the curve that
we used for the launcher.
I won't bore you with details.
It's basically a Bezier
curve with some extra details
here and there.
So this is a kind of maths
that you might want to do.
It's not as scary as
it looks, it's fine.
And then when you have
the maths for the path,
this is how you would
actually use it in code.
And this line here is the
crucial one where you just
get the tangent line
to the path you have,
and then apply the positions
to the children in the view.
So here again, this is
the general architecture
of the API.
This is all provided in the
Wear UI support library, which
is now part of Android
Support Library, which means
it's going to get open sourced.
And this is the chosen path
that you need to provide.
What is specifically not
provided is the scaling,
but that's pretty trivial.
We didn't provide
this part of the API
because you might want to put
in different shapes of children
into the wearable recycler view.
So to learn more
about this API, you
can search for
wearable recycler view.
The curving layout callback
and generally curved
layout Android Wear.
It's in the developer
documentation,
and obviously you
can just Google it.
There's plenty of stuff
on Stack Overflow.
So that's all from me.
I hope this has
going to be helpful.
And with that I'll
hand over to Dan.
DANIEL GALPIN: All
right, thank you.
That was pretty awesome.
All right, let's jump
right into AAudio,
because we're short on time.
First of all, why a new API?
We already have open
SLES and Java APIs.
But we've listened to a
lot of developer feedback
and you guys have told us that
audio processing with open SLES
is really hard, and we think
we can make it easier to use.
And you know, all of
these original APIs
go through the original
audio flinger framework.
But since making huge changes
there could potentially
break lots of apps,
AAudio has a new server,
so we can do some pretty
radical things that
should get us some big
performance enhancements.
So it uses the
concept of streams.
And in this case, we can see
a stream flowing from the mic
all the way back to the
app, and all the way back
to the headphones.
And these streams are
straightforward to create
using a builder
design pattern, which
allows you to create a
builder with your requested
customizations that
can be then used
to create multiple streams.
And this is kind of cool.
You can actually set up the
builder as kind of a rubber
stamp to create audio streams.
So in this code we have
the AAudio stream builder.
And this gets you a default
stream, which is probably
a stereo audio output stream.
And here's how you would
request specific values
for direction and format.
So you can see you get input
and output streams from this.
And once you set
up the stream you
can call open stream
on the builder.
And if you didn't set
things like the sample
rate and format, you'll
need to query them.
And finally, you'll get
the frames per burst
from the audio stream to get
the optimal read-write size.
And this is kind of
how this all works.
In AAudio, a buffer refers to
these arrays of these bursts.
And data is written
in these bursts
through the DAC, which
actually turns audio
into something your
headphones can actually hear.
And in this diagram,
this app, has
generated two bursts of
data, and the first burst
will be written.
And as you might expect, you
can start, and pause, and flush
or stop your stream, and
all with asynchronous calls.
And for most use
cases this is optimal.
But we do have functions you
can synchronize these things
if you need to.
All right, again,
it's a simple API.
We've got to cover
it in six minutes.
So how do you get data in
and out of the streams?
OK, so for apps that don't
need super low latency,
you can just use
blocking writes.
And here we're in a
loop, and the blocking
write function returns either
the number of frames written
or an error.
And this blocking
write can time out,
so we might only get part
of the frames written.
So we need to make sure
to handle that case.
But when you need
the lowest latency,
you need to be running
on a special thread
to do your audio processing on.
Maybe one that's
scheduled with SCHED_FIFO.
So you write this
callback function,
and AAudio will pass through
the stream parameter, any user
data that you need, the audio
data buffer, and the number
of frames, and then you
can render your audio right
into that audio buffer on
the high priority thread.
So you set up this callback
actually in the building.
All right, some people
were like, well,
what I really want to do
is do audio processing.
That means I need to
take audio that comes in
and turn it into something.
How do I do that?
How do I mix two or
more input streams
and send it to an output?
So what you do we recommend
is using the stream
as the master callback,
usually the output stream.
And in this simple
example, we're
just passing data
from input to output.
Oh, I love my square there.
And we read from the input
stream with a zero timeout
to do a non-blocking read.
And that goes right
into the output buffer.
And notice that it may take a
couple of calls for these two
streams to synchronize.
The output stream, input stream.
OK, finally let's talk about
dynamic latency tuning.
And this is kind of important.
Because looking back at
our previous diagram,
we have two bursts ready
to be consumed by the DAC.
And if we're glitching because
we're getting preempted
all the time, we might
want to add another burst
to our renderer.
And so this is kind of the
way we do this simplified.
We can detect
overruns or underruns
we've had on our output stream
by calling get x run count.
And if it's changed
since the last time
you checked you've got a glitch.
So you can just add another
burst to your buffer size.
Pretty straightforward.
So once again, here is basic
AAudio using a blocking write.
OK, really simple.
We've got a stream builder.
We've opened a stream.
Pretty straightforward.
We request start.
And then while we're processing,
we just write frames.
Like kind of how you
should work, right?
And then we close it and
we're done, because you know,
we're always good.
And this is a C
API, so we really
need to make sure
we close things.
And here is just a
partial equivalent
of what we'd have to
do this in open SLES.
So again, you know,
the goal is not just
to only make audio
higher performance,
but it also gives us-- it
makes it much easier to write
these programs entirely.
And so now you're saying,
like, but wait, this
is only in Android O. How
am I going to use this?
And so the good news we have
for that is that we're actually
working on a C++ wrapper.
And this wrapper
is not only going
to be able to target
Android O and AAudio,
but it's actually going to
work on older Android platforms
as well.
And so you'll actually be able
to use this new simplified
interface-- in fact, in
some ways almost easier
because it's C++--
on both older and newer
versions of Android.
So pretty cool.
It's going to have
similar concepts.
It's going to use DLsim.
It's just going to use
DLsim runtime linking
to talk to AAudio, or it's
going to have a backend that
talks to open SLES.
So cool, and that's it.
We've covered it
in four minutes.
It's that easy.
And it really is.
Like, honestly, the
audio developers
we've worked with who've used
this API already have come back
and said thank you.
How many people here
have actually tried
using open SLES to
do their audio app?
See?
That's how popular it is!
Anyway, so on behalf of myself
and all of the presenters
who've come to the stage
do lightning talks,
thank you all for coming.
And you know, we're going
to have office hours.
So today you can come to
Android Wear office hours.
We're going to have Android
Auto office hours tomorrow,
and ExoPlayer office hours.
So if there are any
burning questions
you had on any of these topics,
please come by and talk to us.
You can also, if you
see me out there,
I can try to answer
questions on AAudio,
which is also pretty cool.
And that's it.
So thank you on
behalf of the panel.
[APPLAUSE]